ok so ungeschminkt ein bisschen zu viel
ok definitiv zu wenig okay was ist das
okay t shirt geht
nein
sie dürfen die braut jetzt küssen
hallo ihr lieben das ist mein 1800
irgendwas kleingedrucktes auch mieten
special alter unfassbare wirklich als
ich das gemacht hatten das sagt jeder
ich hätte das erwartet
natürlich
also wie ich das so in den anderen
kanälen wollte sehen ob ist endlich
irgend ein musikinstrument zu spielen
ohne sieg endlich spielen kann und zwar
an
also fettes fett ist danke ich werde
euch nicht enttäuschen nicht wer fleißig
versuchen weiter videos zu machen und
alle meine ideen auf dem kopf im
bildformat rausbringt hoffentlich
gelingt mir das auch immer besser zu
werden so bildtechnisch und so aber
haltet die ohren steif in folge wurde
ich gespannt davon und zwergen und
riesen und parkscheiben und natürlich
von aspirin complex ihr mittel bei
schnupfen mit schmerzen und fieber im
rahmen einer geltung bzw eines grippalen
infekts
und jetzt gibt mir allein kurs